Now suppose you implement
par.for in this way.
Let's replace par.for
with a procedure call.
This procedure call takes the function,
or the loop body,
as well as an iteration range.
In this case 1 to n.
The procedure call itself
is implemented as follows.
We figure out how many
iterations there are,
call that little n if there's only one
iteration, and we'll call foo on a.
Otherwise, we'll do divide and conquer.
Essentially breaking the iteration
range a to b into a to m-1, and m to b.
Where m is approximately the midpoint.
This scheme will give you the usual
sort of binary tree recursion.
So if you ask, what's the span of
this DAG, it should be logarithmic.
Now what I've just given you is a much
more realistic way to implement
a parallel for loop.
So what I want you to do from now on
is to assume this implementation.
That means if I tell you that the loop
body of a par.for has constant cost,
and I ask you what the span is,
the span will be log n.
And, again, this is in contrast to
assuming that the span is, say,
constant cost.
Which is what it would be in theory.